il représente près de 20% de l'économie
du pays le tourisme un pilier sur lequel
s'appuie depuis longtemps la grèce mais
avec la pandémie de kobe 19
le secteur s'est écroulé la saison
touristique 2020 a été cauchemardesque
avec une fréquentation des voyageurs en
baisse de 70% pour éviter une nouvelle
déconvenue alors que le pays enregistre
toujours plus de 2000 cas de co vide en
moyenne par jour
un plan de déconfinement été
minutieusement préparée par le
gouvernement dès le début du mois
d'avril les commerces non essentiels ont
pu rouvrir
alors que les vols internationaux depuis
les principaux aéroports grecs ont
repris le 3 mai dernier les terrasses
des bars et restaurants ont rouvert
quelques jours avant les plages alors
que les cinémas en plein air ouvriront
d'ici une semaine suivie par les
théâtres
nous avons attendu très longtemps pour
pouvoir recevoir ici tous les touristes
et les citoyens qui peuvent prendre le
soleil et profiter de la mer toutes les
mesures nécessaires sont prises pour que
tout le monde vienne et soient en
sécurité ici profite du soleil et de la
mer mais en même temps soit en sécurité
et qu'aucun virus ne se propage
le plan de déconfinement est en grande
partie lié à celui de la vaccination
près d'un tiers de la population grecque
a déjà reçu 12 du sérum anti qu'ovide et
12 % des habitants sont totalement
vacciner mais le gouvernement grec veut
désormais prioriser les territoires
enclin au tourisme
nous donnons à nos îles la priorité en
ouvrant la vaccination à toute la
population adulte avant que ce soit le
cas dans le reste de la grèce le but est
que tous les habitants permanents des
îles soient entièrement vacciner d'ici
la fin juin
athènes a multiplié les accords pour
faciliter l'accès à son pays depuis le
19 avril les voyageurs de certains états
dont la france n'était plus soumis à un
isolement de sept jours à leur arrivée
sur le sol grec et pour faciliter
davantage la venue de voyageurs le
gouvernement n'hésite pas à promouvoir
le passeport vaccinale européen
je pense que nous avons vu le pire du
coc vide et je m'attends à ce que nous
nous dirigions vers un été plus normal
il est évident que nous avons un grand
intérêt commun à promouvoir le
certificat vert pour faire en sorte que
les visiteurs notamment ceux d'europe du
nord
voyage en europe du sud si le chiffre
des 34 millions de touristes accueillis
en 2019 semble inatteignable cet été la
grèce compte bien faire mieux que les
7,4 millions de visiteurs de l'an
dernier